lady yeah hello I'm Mario and up until
recently I wasn't always known for
having the best sense of fashion Jack
and I were pivotal in arias style
transformation he started off with his
khakis v-necks all he loved his v-neck
I specifically remember one day I pulled
him aside and I said aria people stopped
wearing v-necks years ago and he was
shook here's the thing it was never
terrible it was an aria the cool
influencer video producer who fought and
got choked in a cage it was Aria the
accountant who has never been in a fight
yeah he works at Staples he will print
you a nice letter he double-sided and so
today I'm giving myself a little
challenged by putting together a very
eclectic outfit topped off by a fedora
this is the fedora that's atrocious
horrid Aria cannot pull off a fit well
not no way I don't think anyone can pull
off a fedora I would like to find a
fedora that looks good it's not out
there it's horrible this is really bad
I'll be wearing this outfit as I go
speed dating tonight to see if my
personality can still win through or
people will still be put off by my look
go change baby show us what you got we
have to say Aria has always been very
handsome yeah he's just now at his prime
do you think Oh God ah this outfit is
just not cute you don't hate it
I know I hate it found something we
decided to get it best from props really
add to the ensemble
this new look got his fair share of
different responses and reactions around
the office I don't like this one it
makes me uncomfortable actually my first
thought was I hate this fine really most
people didn't seem to like it very much
I think it's it's safe to say I think it
was it's it's a nightmare the funny
thing is this isn't that far off from
how are you used to dress if you saw a
guy walking down the street like this
yeah what would you think I'm going
speed dating in this outfit tonight
trying to find a date tonight wearing
this outfits the first day I'm not sure
how much luck do you think I'm gonna
have what do you think Merle will think
about his outfit arjan Merle have been
spending some time together and they've
really only been spending time together
since Aria had his glow up and so now
he's glowed back and I fear a
backsliding for relationship I can't
wait to see her reaction lady has such a
good sense of humor so she's really
gonna thrive with this I think she's
gonna have a good time with it you look
a little bit like you might be creepin
in my bushes which let's be honest he
probably is well you know what I love
[Music]
from here up
I can dig it mm-hmm here down I do not
dig it
it doesn't flatter his body this is not
doing him justice I'm more worried what
she'll think about Arya going on dates
you're gonna have blind date almost peed
in it don't be too jealous
let me feel about that he is very
confident person so I think he'll be
okay but like I'm worried about people
making fun of him that being said
you know handsome man so he'll be fine
so thanks to the company my cheeky date
I mean my first speed dating experience
right here and what better way to get
your first speed dating experience am I
really putting yourself through a
challenge what's also great is that even
though I'll be there and let's get up
there will actually be a bunch of other
single men they're looking for love so
even if the other women don't find love
with me they also find love with one of
the other guys the only one critical
rule that I have to follow tonight is
that I can't reveal my real name or my
profession because if they know that I'm
a buzz B producer that I'm here with the
camera crew then they're gonna be
influenced and I want them to see me for
who I am with this outfit so Aria makes
a very good first impression and a good
second impression then when you get to
know him he's scary but off the first
impression I think that people will be
really charmed arias a handsome man so I
think he has that going for him I do
think the outfit will not help if he had
any hard time finding love before and
based on his previous projects multiple
videos where he tries to find love
unsuccessfully this is not gonna be the
one wouldn't it be a really fun a great
thing that Aria finds love in this video
I did have to lie about my name my name
is Fernando Pedro I'm Fernanda padrone
well I miss Fernando good Oh Fernando
patrasche
first time for me what do you think you
do for over-limit I'm very I'm very
scared of needles I couldn't say that I
work at entertainment or for BuzzFeed so
you know I had to lie about my
profession I'm an MMA fighter several
times I'm a songwriter I work at the W I
spray water on them before their shoots
good had some fun with that I sell
things on the dark one
I really say six merits is a fun way to
get to know someone with six minutes you
can just know your chemistry right away
and I think I go along with all the
women Christmas is my favorite time of
the year are you a big fan of Evil Dead
Man it went better than I could have
even imagined this is like my third time
doing this and it's probably my favorite
one I would go on probably - oh yeah
there was a solid six one of them whose
name was bridge
Aaron was cool yeah very cool
yes Patrick I liked Patrick I don't
remember Patrick don't remember Patrick
at all yes I remember the guy with the
fedora
he was memorable Fernando Fernando was
like oh okay had the Hat well he was
wearing a hat too so we definitely
connected the Hat people which are very
musical
she dies at the end very sad
Fernando sang to me Fernando was really
cool
you're like my real overall touchdown
Fernando wrote a song with Michael Buble
and saying a song to me so that was
pretty cool super dope he was really
nice he was very personable he was
hilarious he was really funny I just
didn't feel the the spark of love we
talked a while about hat so I didn't
totally get to know him but I would be
interested in seeing him again because
he was fun
oh yeah for sure and with or without hat
I mean he could have like a cone for all
I know yeah yeah I mean like it was
weird but yeah there just be a word
second date ultimately would I go on a
second date with any of these women I
didn't feel anything I had a nice time
with a lot of them but as i sat there
seeing these people looking for romance
ultimately I realized there is one
person that I do actually want to go on
a date with No hi
the the speed-dating just ended so I
thought I'd give you a call it was an
experience it was I did not I did not
get lucky you should be very relieved I
didn't get I didn't get lucky you know I
know how much you like this look we can
give some vegan ice cream with this with
this hat my fedora and I will be over
very very shortly
[Music]
the were there were a couple of people
that you know that I think we're feeling
this
[Music]